but what's the point of it
i know that's kind of a really broad
question but what is the point of it
it's not broad it's a very narrow
question okay
good what you're asking is what's the
point of life yeah
such a question comes because in some
way it's become burdensome
if you are ecstatic you wouldn't ask
that question
isn't it
in a moment of great joy you don't ask
that question right you ask that
question because somewhere your feet are
dragging
because you don't have the throttle
under your right foot anymore
good one really good one
so
get back in the car driving at the speed
limit you're feeling what is the point
of life
exactly you understand me so well
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast on
the show today is sad guru who is a
pretty intensely spiritual man he is a
renowned speaker he's a best-selling
author and founder of the isha
foundation
whose mission is to raise human
consciousness through individual
transformation for any of you out there
who have done any sort of spiritual
diving you've no doubt come across side
guru so it was a true honor to speak to
him his wisdom is is wide and deep you
know he's also very playful and fun so
he has a real true understanding of the
human experience and how to
essentially
escape
well his newest book karma get out of
your karma to leave your karma behind as
he would refer to it kind of like the
bag that that's what we talked about
most most of the show was how our memory
affects us and ways to make peace with
it essentially become a happier human
being which i think is probably just
about something that anyone would want
more of and satguru is definitely
someone who sits there in a lot of joy
and i think that you'll hear that today
on the show what is that not your name
but what is a name anyway
name
if we
if you look at it properly
name is
any word any utterance is just a sound
but you can either have make a sound
which fits
the nature of your reverberation
or you can just have a name which is
culturally relevant but not relevant to
you as a person
so in india we take enormous care
to choose a name which fits the child
when they grow up
when they mature many times we change
the name because they have changed
their reverberations have changed
accordingly we change the name
it
at different times that to three to four
times you could change the name
have you always had the same name
nobody calls me by my name so it's okay
except my daughter wow how many names
have you had
uh
generally
in this lifetime
[Laughter]
no only one name but generally people
call me satguru now except my girl
everybody else calls me satguru now so
how did you get that name
well uh it's still it's not a name it's
more a description
in the sense uh
suppose uh
you go because you have some problem in
your eye if you go
will you go to an orthopedic if you have
a bone problem
you will not go to a neurologist you
will go to an orthopedic like this
so satguru is a description
you want to learn scriptures you don't
go to him because he knows no scriptures
you want to know some tradition you
don't go to him because he has no
tradition
you want to know some ritual you don't
go to him because he knows no rituals
he knows only one thing he is completely
uneducated about the spiritual
culture
he knows only one thing he knows this
life from its origin to its ultimate if
you are interested in knowing life
you go to him if you want to know
something else you don't go to him so
it's a simple description satguru means
a guru of the within
not of
the sacred books or texts or gods and
heavens he doesn't all that he knows
only this
how did you get that information how did
you is it getting the information or is
it remembering tell me are you an
information or a living life
living life that's it that's what i am
but it's so where do you call me an
information
because it is information for so many
i've come to ask questions for
information
what you get from me will not be
information
the word guru means this
that goo means darkness
means dispeller one who dispels your
darkness is guru
so you can say you can call guru a
sadhguru a torchlight if you want
now where do you want to flash it you
tell me that's your questions we'll
decide where we want to flash the
torchlight
do you flash the torchlight
when it's not asked ever or is it only
if it's invited when it's not asked i
have a big light bulb
everything is lit
but people cannot see
they need focus light on something
because
they've made their minds like a keyhole
which is the tragedy of human existence
the human experience is so fascinating
to me i
i watch and listen and try and
understand it
but what's the point of it
i know that's kind of a really broad
question but what is the point of it
it's not broad it's a very narrow
question okay
good what you're asking is what's the
point of life yeah
such a question comes because in some
way it's become burdensome
if you are ecstatic you wouldn't ask
that question
isn't it
in a moment of great joy you don't ask
that question right you ask that
question because somewhere your feet are
dragging
because you don't have the throttle
under your right foot anymore
good one really good one
[Laughter]
driving at the speed limit you feeling
what is the point of life
exactly you understand me so well
but speed limits are there
on the regular street when i first came
to united states
nearly 20 22 years ago
because i'm always used to
putting the throttle to the floorboard
wherever i am if the motorcycle is full
on touching the springs and sometimes
cutting off the springs
because it's it was never enough
for me
this is a strange thing when i was
riding way back
about five times i cut off the brass
one pin will be there inside the
carburetors of a two-stroke engine at
that time we were riding two-stroke
engines
first time it happened i just couldn't
figure out what happened because
if i start the motorcycle it starts if i
try to throttle up it goes off
i took it to somebody who's kind of an
expert
he looked at it and he couldn't figure
it out
not knowing we thought the dynamo is
gone so which the dynamo could be
charged those days only in the
manufacturing unit so we took it there
one whole day i sat there and got it
charged and brought it back still the
same thing
then i realized
it is something unheard of
the brass pin which is in the thing when
you throttle up it comes up and there's
a butterfly around it you know that's
how it was made
so that has gotten cut
because i'm holding the throttle full on
like this
and after that it happened five times
then i knew every time it happened i cut
i always started carrying one extra pin
oh you are my guru
so when in some way you don't live your
life joyfully enough intensely enough
you wonder
what is the point of my existence
because human intelligence is made this
way if it doesn't figure out
if it doesn't figure out all aspects of
life it will feel incomplete
if you had the brains of an earthworm or
a grasshopper you would be fine eating
sleeping reproducing and dying one day
but once you come with this level of
intelligence and awareness
you have to look deeper into your life
because your life is not fixed like
their life
nature has drawn two lines for all of
them they just have to live within that
and go
for you there are no lines
this freedom is what everybody's
suffering
so some people try to go beyond lines by
sitting in a race car
some people do it by doing crime some
people do it by doing adventure yes you
see crime yes that is in a way to break
lines
you need to understand because i've i've
worked uh with uh you know like we have
a program called enough freedom for
imprisoned which is mandatory in all
southern indian prisons now and also we
did programs here in kentucky in
pennsylvania tennessee and other areas
in the prisons
i have spent so much time with hardcore
criminals
doing these programs
what i saw was
this is their way of racing
breaking speed limits
your way of doing it is you went to the
track if you did the same thing on the
street you would be in the prison yes so
they didn't get sponsored they didn't
get a car they didn't get a machine they
didn't get a situation in their life
where they could create a race is a
controlled
uh situation to commit crime
as far as the local trooper is concerned
i'm saying yeah yes yeah it's a
controlled atmosphere where it's made
reasonably safe for everybody
the risk is only for those who want who
have that madness in them
but if you do it on the street the risk
is for everybody so it becomes a crime
but it's the same thing
if you have a high powered car on the
street and you race when i first came to
united states
mother what is the problem because i am
not
i'm never going to drive in such a way
it's going to be dangerous for somebody
else
but if i'm not on the edge of danger i
can't live
okay
so i'm like hitting it really full
throttle and people are saying
you should not drive like this in
america it's not like india you can
drive at your own speed people in india
do drive crazy so fast yes so fast
i drive much faster in india than i do
in america wow so first couple of visits
i made i'm driving i said what's the
problem there's power in the engine and
the road is wide open what is it
no no you can't do this they'll handcuff
you they'll do this i said why
then i don't listen to what others say i
just observe then i see
a 80 year old woman is driving a school
bus and going if i go wish
she may go fall off somewhere all right
so then i
understood the speed limits
do you think are we all i mean you say
that you need something to help you
bring you to the edge is this part of
the human experience to
um
or the human burden is this a burden in
our life that helps us learn lessons to
have that sort of
breaking the lines aspect to us so you
can call it breaking the line
essentially
it is a freedom offered only to the
human being in this
massive life that exists on this planet
for all of them clearly drawn out lines
by nature you can do this you cannot do
this you're a tiger you're a lion you're
a grasshopper you're an earthworm
whatever the hell you are including the
virus okay right lines are fixed by
nature
for you lions are not fixed so human
beings are not suffering their bondages
they're suffering their freedom because
they don't know how to deal with it
let's unpack that
it's the freedom that there's the
freedom that they're suffering why do
you think everybody's trying to bind
themselves to somebody
because they cannot be free if they're
free they feel terrified
somebody has to hold their hand all the
time
see i cannot live without you or i can
[Laughter]
you taking
whether i say i cannot live without you
or i cannot walk without a crotch what
is the difference i'm asking
see right now we we made it very
romantic yes if i say i cannot live
without you that's supposed to be the
best thing no i can live perfectly
without you right but by choice i'm
having you here right isn't this a great
thing right absolutely i cannot live
without you you are my crutch why do we
use those words then those are the
romantic words because i can't live
without you why do we use those words
that is because your life is being
shaped by sappy novels and hollywood
last scene live to have lived happily
ever after kind of
scenes i think those scenes are
generally gone these days they're from
scenes from 60s 70s
80s also maybe to some extent
um
it's so true it is true you there there
is a programming that comes from
television from books uh and and do you
think this is commercial commercial
forces are determining your
consciousness that's the sickest way to
develop a human society but it's
happening right of course
big time do you watch tv
news channels
not every day i would like to but
in united states i don't even get to
read a newspaper there isn't any
newspaper anywhere in any home
in india in every home there will be a
newspaper in our homes there will be
five
news five editions of different brands
of newspaper because we have to look at
a newspaper online news is there but
it's not the same thing
television
indian television has become full of
debates not much news you have to search
for news
and every two minutes somebody will come
and send a
sell a hammer an underwear anything yeah
in the in your face
to get 10 minutes of news you'll have to
buy a hammer a screwdriver an underwear
a car and whatever
very expensive to watch the news
so you have to keep shifting to five
different channels to get a little bit
of news here there there
programming and purchasing
so what is the right programming then
freedom means no programming program
means you're set
no freedom freedom means to be able to
live here without a program
what's the definition of
nirvana
nirvana before i know it's a popular
word in california nirvana means
non-existence are you ready for that
right
you want nirvana you can hat you have no
programming essentially then no
non-existence that you don't exist
are you ready for non-existence people
are just using these words picked up
from books and scriptures i've been
thinking a lot about abracadabra and how
words
are
spells and so that feels like
of course programming that you get from
your television or your newspaper and
the words that you say to each other
like
i can't live without you
that's powerful in a good and bad way
when i say i cannot live without you
what is being satisfied within you is
your insecurity right
that you have hold over me
if i say
i can live absolutely joyfully without
with without you
but
i'm choosing to have you here
this is valuable
this is the best acknowledgement for who
you are exactly i cannot live without
you you could ask me as will be a stick
that i hold and walk
so that should be
how you address the person that you love
then right those should be the new the
new words are
i don't need you but i'm glad you're
here this is a joyful experience but i
don't need you
that's the most loving thing you could i
understand that i agree
i i agree i i i think that uh of course
needing anything is see we have raised
need about joy need about love need
about freedom needs are everything
because it's a market economy if you
don't have needs what will the economy
do what are they going to sell you don't
need anything what do they sell
i'm not good for the economy they're
telling me they tell me sadhguru you
don't have credit history
i say isn't it good i've never taken a
loan isn't it great
they said no you have no credit history
you have no value in united states you
must buy something
i think i don't need anything why should
i buy something
we play into that system your book
karma and i have been reading a lot
about karma and i've always read a lot
about karma and i'm sure i use it in the
wrong context but in all of the things
that i've watched and read and and
understood within me feels like
karma is some is is could be also
another word that could be used as
perception
is that accurate
karma is post per perception perception
has happened
the residual impact of perception is
karma the residual impact
see right now whatever you perceive
right
all of it may not remain in the
conscious plane of who you are right now
you look like this there are
a hundred different shades of green out
there right
you may not be conscious about it
but all of it has been captured by your
eye and registered somewhere within you
so next time you see that
it will naturally make its own judgments
the dark green may create fear in you
light green may create joy in you i'm
saying
just ad hoc i'm just saying but i'm
saying different colors different tastes
different smells different sounds create
either fear or joy in you your race car
if my
father heard that race car engine he
would have a nervous breakdown really
yeah yeah he hated my motorcycle when i
revved up because i'm just tuning it and
ma'am if i do that shut up
so he hates your race car but for you
it's like music
the smell of oil and gas
that's all pollution that's called
pollution in california but it smells
good to me that's my perception
it's perfume that is your karma
because what everybody pursues gasoline
smell as gasoline smell
they may not call that call it by that
name but it's the same smell
but one person
registers it as a wonderful thing
another person says this is pollution
this is not perfume
so
how you register it and how it remains
within you that's your karma that will
determine the next moment's experience
for you right not allowing that to
determine your next moment's experience
is freedom
what is it that we get wrong about karma
and understanding it who is that we
most people
everything wrong
[Laughter]
i know
i know that's why i'm coming to you
um but i feel like you know
karma there's a there's a there's a
perception that karma perception of the
perception uh that you know you do
something bad and then something
you know you get away with it and
something but i feel like that's not an
accurate or or deep enough understanding
of karma first of all how do you decide
something is bad racing is bad okay
racing is bad a whole lot of people
now because
you know my truck has gone on the
instagram or something a whole lot of
people are saying this is a crime when
india is suffering from pandemic he is
driving a truck
what would you want me to drive a
helicopter i can do that a plane i can
do that a boat i can do that what would
you what would you want me to drive no
i'll tell you this one day i'm driving
you know like i'm going to a conference
in chennai in southern india
somebody else is driving now it's very
rare that somebody else drives it's
somebody else's car they're driving i'm
staying in someone's home
and they're driving in a very civilized
way and we're not going anywhere
chennai needs a little forceful driving
otherwise you won't get anywhere
it's getting late for me and
i've maintained this in the last 39
years i have not been late to a single
event in my life
so
speed is a part of that that i get there
and i hear you
so i i so in a traffic lamp i told the
driver you just get off
i made him get off i got in and started
driving
so i got to the hotel where the
conference was
you know these days after that mumbai
terrorist attack in every star hotel
good hotel that you go to there is a
security gate
there's two security guys who definitely
do not know what they're looking for
okay
they will just look at you like this
like this they don't see a damn thing
you can see that and he just opens the
boot and closes it he doesn't see
anything and he puts a mirror under the
car
that you're carrying a bomb like that
i'm carrying a bomb under my seat how
will you see it
only thing is he's thinking he will
scare the terrorists he'll make him
nervous and catch him
but anyway that little barrier which is
there a terrorist will crash through
that and go
it is not a barrier that can stop a car
saying right right
so anyway one car went and this thing
went up and i squeezed myself through
that and when then everybody started
blowing their whistles
i just went parked in the portion of the
thing i just left the car there and ran
into the conference hall straight on the
stage
spoke for an hour
hour and then i came when i ran in i saw
some journalists standing there they saw
me they thought this is it we caught him
you know
i didn't break any law because this is a
private area you go through the barrier
it is only hotel rules not
traffic rules smart you're smart
then when i came out they asked me
in ancient times yogis used to walk
now you drive your own car what kind of
a yogi are you then i said you idiots in
ancient times everybody was walking not
just the yogis today everybody is
driving ayogi is also driving and he
drives a little better that's all the
problem is
and you drive a little better than at
the average i'm guessing
i drive well enough to
though from the age of 12 i've been
riding and then driving and everything
i've driven across the world i'm still
alive so i must be driving okay
that's what i say
memory
i feel like i i listen to a lot about
memory and how
memory is intertwined with karma
memory is karma
karma is memory that's why i said it's a
residual impact
right now what is in your conscious
memory is not even one percent of what
is actually there
see
you definitely don't remember
you being an amoeba do you remember no
but your body remembers
today
i'm sorry i have to use such horrible
examples can i yeah it's a bad example
any example let's say
you love cats and then you decided
because they don't like your food you
decided to eat their food out of your
love you know because love means that i
should do what you like sure yeah
exactly
all right yeah so you started eating cat
food in two months time will you turn
into a cat no every cell in your body
remembers
that you are a human being this is
called evolutionary memory it will not
forget
every cell in your body thinks why this
dumb idiot is eating cat food
we can do better yes but it will not
turn you into cat cells or cat body all
right because there is evolutionary
memory it will not get confused do what
you want
now ten generations ago your great great
great grandmother how she looked do you
remember no no
but her nose may be sitting on your face
right now exactly the way it was
a million years ago what was the skin
texture of your forefathers
still on isn't it
so
this whole thing what you call as myself
is simply memory this is your karma
because you have that kind of memory
you tend to automatically act in a
particular way
this is karma
so why we want to be free from karma is
because we don't want to be an extension
of the past we want to be a fresh life
if you want to be a fresh life you must
be able to stand in the richness of your
memory and do your act now
fresh act
but
if you sink into this memory then you
will be doing only the past thinking it
is the future
is there any escaping that though of
course
see i
i'm escaped
i'm a yogi means i'm supposed to sit
like this
see
i'm doing everything i can
just to freak them out a little bit do
you have to face the memory
to heal it no no no no
see the in
what is there as memory in this
i'm sorry i'm using such words i know
these are negative words in social
context
this is a bag of memory that you call as
my body
out of this there is a mechanism called
mind which is also memory out of this is
a mechanism called emotion that is also
memory out of this there is energetic
activity that is also memory all of this
is controlled by the type of memory
impressions that you have
evolutionary
uh genetic karmic and variety of other
memories this whole amalgamation of a
complex
influx of memories which are happening
to you right now as you look at me as
you look at the garden as you hear
things as you hear the birds as you hear
the automobiles memories getting piled
up
otherwise you wouldn't be able to
recognize anything see right now an
automobile is something which has been a
part of you in many ways
now suppose you had no memory of an
automobile you have never seen one you
never heard one
if i start an automobile it was
then you'll think what is it
once you have heard it and you know it's
an automobile after 10 years if you hear
it you know this is an automobile
how only by previous imprint isn't it
these imprints are far more complex than
you understand
it goes back to an amoeba
all that memory is here
now you don't try to decipher that
because if you try to decipher that
you'll get buried in that memory the
simple thing is
make it uh create enough surface tension
so that it doesn't pop at you all the
time and now it's your stage
if you have a lot of memory
phenomenal amount of memory
bo there is no such thing as good memory
and bad memory they're just memory
memory means it is past impressions
yesterday can neither be good nor bad
isn't it now
it's over right it cannot be good it
cannot be bad but if you just get
entangled with your memory yesterday can
be bad yesterday can be good right a
whole lot of time most people are living
like this they are not suffering their
life they are suffering their memory
isn't it you said that suffering is
being stuck
in a memory you can't escape can't get
over no right no no i didn't say the
last you didn't say that i didn't say it
in your words please see people are
suffering what happened
10 years ago
what happened 10 years ago does it exist
right now no it's nowhere here
it's only in your memory
so you're suffering this
what is memory what is human memory
compared to the memory of every other
creature on the planet
our memory is far more vivid
than anybody else's memory on this
planet as human beings
this vividness of memory it what gives
us richness of life
because we grasp see right now if i look
at your face i am grasping many aspects
of it which a dog may not grasp a catman
or grass but grasshopper may not grasp
but as a human eye and human
neurological process i am grasping
various aspects
of just one face on the planet the
detail that i am grasping nobody else
grasped except a human being
if you have enough attention
you grasp much more
because of this ability to grasp and
perceive things we have a massive sense
of memory
vivid sense of memory now this vivid
sense of memory is what sets us apart
from every other creature the richness
of life and that's what people are
suffering
because
they do not know how to handle their own
memory and their own imagination
if they had let's say yesterday a thorn
went into their
foot
now everywhere they're thinking every
blade of grass is thorn
or somebody is a lala
they think they're walking on flowers
all the time there are people like that
in california because they're on some
they're on something else not on
gasoline
in california
how do we
make peace with our memory
see how do you make peace with something
that doesn't exist
but we have it so we're in this
conundrum
see the memory is there there is no such
reality
it you are misunderstanding your
psychological process as a reality that
is the fundamental mistake
your thought and emotion you think it is
real
it is not it's just something that
you're making up
if you know you're making it up
then what is the problem there's nothing
to deal with
because it doesn't exist
the problem is you've been you've been
given a very complex
level of intelligence which includes
memory and imagination
but you don't have a stable enough
platform
this platform is not stable enough you
know let me put it like this you heard
of that english guy because you were in
uk for some time you must have met this
guy called charles darwin did you meet
him no no didn't happen in some way you
met him in the school textbook at least
okay yeah exactly
exactly
so charles darwin went out to say that a
good could have become a giraffe in some
million years a pig could have become an
elephant in many more million years
something something like this all right
an ant could have become an adenosir
right over a billion years whatever
but
a monkey became a man rather quickly i
mean a woman also okay don't take it
you know how many times i've been
generalized as a guy it does not bother
me so
so
a monkey became a human being rather too
quickly
how quickly means
the dna difference between a chimpanzee
and a human being is only point two
three percent
one point two three percent is not much
of a difference isn't it
so physiologically that is how close you
are to a chimpanzee but in terms of
intelligence and awareness your worlds
apart so essentially human beings do not
know how to handle their own
intelligence because they don't have a
stable enough platform
one important and significant aspect of
the yogic sciences is to create a stable
platform
so that your intelligence works for you
if your intelligence works for you would
you keep yourself blissful or miserable
blissful yes bless
if you are in some way miserable for
whatever reason for whatever reason you
just lost a race or you crashed your car
whatever the hell the reason is if you
are miserable it simply means your
intelligence is working against you it's
as simple as that and you're in the
memory
and you're in the memory
uh your intelligence is not working
for you that means it doesn't decipher
what is reality and what is memory what
is reality and what is imagination
how do we get our intelligence to work
for us before the race are you taking
anti-diarrheal pills
no some people are i know
because imagination
is going wild
this is human predicament you do not
know how to handle your own intelligence
that is the thing if you had the brain
of an earthworm you would be peaceful
no nerves
now to intelligence
is is it a solution or is it a problem
what is a question i don't know it
sounds like it's a problem after all
this what should it be
intelligence is a solution
intelligence is a solution for
everything isn't it but human beings
have made it a problem because they
don't have a stable enough platform for
it the most important thing is this from
early childhood we must strive
to create a stable platform
within a human being
so that oh there's a whole system
of as there is a technology and science
for external well-being to create
external well-being similarly there's a
whole science and technology for inner
well-being but right now our life is not
about being wonderful our life is about
how to be better than somebody i want
you to be number two in the race
next indy 500 if both of us are there i
want you number two
who's number one
of course me
i'm saying this is the problem
that
you you're not seeing how to make this
into the most wonderful possible life
you're always seeing how to be better
than somebody
so this race is not just on the
racetrack on the racetrack it's okay we
know it's a sport all right but this is
with life itself
now
if you are on the racetrack what is your
goal you want to hit the finish line
first right
are they doing this how are they doing
you're totally right that's exactly how
they do it yeah sometimes they usually
you want to see the checkered flag
that's right quick
so if you believe your life is a race
what do you think is the finish line
that's a great question
uh
enlightenment or death maybe someone
thinks death i don't know
what is the finish line for life
for the race the finish line is
checkered flag right for life the finish
line is coffin
yes yes do you want to get there soon
no no
then don't think it's a race it's not a
race against anybody
this is about you blossoming to your
fullest possibility
so many people would say how do i
accomplish anything if i don't have
goals and i don't have some kind of
inertia pushing me through life and
inertia doesn't push inertia slows you
down
right now that's all they're doing
because see let us say you have only one
leg
and you're hopping around
i have two legs but i want to be better
than you what will i do i will try to
hop a little faster than you how
ridiculous is that
that's ridiculous you just run that's
what is happening that's what is
happening to people
i was just telling somebody it once
happened
i'm sorry i've just said that in another
talk i had an hour ago but let me say
this because it's very important because
you're a racer
and in the race of course you want to be
the first one to cross the line you want
to see the checkered flag first nothing
wrong with that because as long as you
understand it's a sport
but everybody wants to see the checkered
flag in their life ahead of everybody
that means they'll see the coffin ahead
of everyone even they may not exactly
die
but even when they're alive they're like
they're dead they're not alive to
anything all right this is what happens
to them because they're always looking
at who is going ahead who's going behind
so i was just telling this person
this is probably i was nine or ten years
of age
so those days and even now i think they
have this system that every month
a report card is given in the school
right
i never understood how my home and
school were connected
i just didn't understand but this report
card was a connection transaction
between my teacher
and my father
and it's a private letter why should i
open it and see i never used to open and
see i understand it oh every time he saw
it he freaked
i thought she must have said something
nasty to him but she was saying
something nasty about me
so once i gave the card and
i had gotten 33rd rank
i was 33.
my father asked how many students in
your class i said 33 of course
isn't 33 a bigger number than number one
hello yeah
how many championships would you like to
win 33 or 1 33
there you are
this whole nonsense we are starting from
kindergarten that you must be better
than somebody what it means is you enjoy
other people's failings
that is sickness that's not joy
it seems like the world is set up kind
of wrong all wrong
we need to fix it what is the solution
well we need to create a conscious
planet that's what we're striving for
right now to create a more conscious
planet if you were conscious you
wouldn't be doing this
you have evolved
out of your monkeyness quite some time
ago
but you're still not acknowledging it
see when i if i say you're monkeying
somebody what does it mean
praying you're imitating somebody right
that's what it means it's synonymous
being a monkey is being synonymous with
imitation so
we've still though
evolution has pushed us out of that
monkey status
one point two three percent
[Laughter]
but it's a world of difference
1.23 is a world of difference but we are
not giving up the old habits this is
karma
so karma means
you are evolutionary you see in your
body
there is memory of every creature
it is not like you as a person became an
amoeba then a grasshopper then this that
not like that as life on this planet has
evolved this body remembers every other
structure of life that is there
and that is why it can maintain its
integrity even if you give it cat food
it can maintain its integrity because
this memory is 100 set
you can't take it somewhere else
you can try to behave like them but this
structure will remain the same because
there is evolutionary memory well
established in the system
similarly genetic memory karmic memory
all these things are there how to be
about that needs
a conscious approach to life
right now
karma gives us an automatic autopilot to
our life
if you just go by our karma
everything is by the tendencies we have
developed it will simply happen somebody
will become this somebody will become
that in a society
but if you want to be about that you can
only do that by being conscious
how to be conscious simplest thing right
now millions of people are doing this
simple process called as isha kriya
see because your karma or all memory
that you have evolutionary genetic
karmic this that every kind of memory
that you have
exists only in your body
and another body which you refer to as
mind but you don't know where it is
hello
right you don't know where it is
everybody says it's it's not like that
every cell in the body has its own
intelligence and its own memory all
right
so there is a mental body there is a
physical body
if you distance yourself from your
physical body and your mental structure
this is the end of karma
because that's where the memory bag is
if you keep the memory bag aside
it's there you know like people can't
keep their phone aside now because like
this like this because it's got some
1000 gb of some nonsense all right going
on
if you just keep it aside and switch it
off
you can sit here it's over right
but they can't do it
because they have no means they've never
seen how
because it is not about the phone
it is because you're compulsive it may
be your phone it may be a cigarette
maybe a drink it may be a food it may be
a person
you can't keep your hands free because
you're compulsive
it may be your
longing for food or pleasure or
something but essentially you're
compulsive
if you're compulsive
you kind of denying your evolutionary
status
because the significance of being human
is we can be conscious
we not doing anything very different
from what the other creatures are doing
they are also just born like us
you know their parents came together
they were born our parents came together
we we are born
we grow up
they grow up very easily we grow up with
a lot of fuss
then what is the next significant thing
that you do as a generation if you look
next thing is maybe we will reproduce
and they will reproduce without fuss you
will reproduce with a lot of fuss and
one day you will die that also with a
lot of us they do it more gracefully
so everything that you do every and to
elephant everybody is doing it
only thing is we can do it consciously
this is a massive difference
that we can do the same simple things
consciously suddenly it's another space
suddenly it's a completely different
possibility if you do not exercise
this ability to be conscious
in every act that you are because
consciousness is not in the act that you
perform right now i hear that
everybody's saying be mindful of this my
be mindful of that mindfulness will make
you a little more alert maybe you'll
survive better than others okay
but consciousness
is your existence so you know you're
here only because you're conscious isn't
it
if you fall asleep and you're
unconscious you don't know where you're
sitting
i mean now somewhere now the question is
you won't know whether you're somewhere
or not when you're sleeping you don't
exist yeah though you're alive
right
you don't exist in your sleep that if
you're sleeping well i'm saying right
right
right now you're conscious
question is only how conscious so now
all you need to do is turn up the
voltage because you cannot be conscious
without generating an intense level of
energy have you noticed when you're on
full throttle
and taking the corner you far more
conscious than sitting on a chair
yes yes now
let me translate that that is not the
way it should be because that is still
alertness
but there is an element of consciousness
in that
suppose
you could keep yourself like that
without the necessary
adrenaline attached to it
without the necessary maybe an element
of fear or danger attached to it if you
could simply sit like here keeping your
blood pressure down
but
as alert as you were taking that corner
at full speed
then you will achieve something that you
have never imagined possible
you will hit a pitch of life that you
never imagined possible people you know
like i was with a group of people keep
inviting me for under 25 conferences
they think i'm under 25. i look like
that don't i they quantify yes under
125.
[Laughter]
that's an insult but it's okay i am too
i am too we all are
125 miles is insult for me
oh i thought we were talking about years
old oh okay okay i was thinking of miles
[Laughter]
well i'm over 125 miles an hour okay
so uh
now they are asking me said guru you
drive so fast is your adrenaline up and
do you enjoy that excitement
i i never thought about this i just look
back and saw when i drive really fast i
become really cool means absolutely
still and cool yeah i'm never excited
when i'm driving very fast i'm like
very very almost become cold literally
simply alert i'm there no no excitement
no adrenaline no such thing in my life
actually you have not enjoyed the power
of stillness that's why you think this
is
this is better amphetamine is better
than being
still
stillness is the nature of the existence
over 99
of the existence which is not material
in nature in this entire cosmos right
not even one percent is material
existence rest is all absolutely still
this is the lap of creation
you must be there always because you are
a piece of creation you are best only
when you're in the lap of creation
so maybe to bring it full circle
to understand because for me it helps to
really understand more of the roots of
the truth about our existence our our
humanness
consciousness
where does it come from
where do we come from
come on don't ask such questions where
do i come from
consciousness though which is
essentially what gives this
uh
what do we call this a memory bag
bag we can call it karmic bag comic bag
permanent bag
right now
to use for any human being
but i'm saying bag because a bag is
something you can carry or you can keep
it down so that's why i'm using the word
bag for you not in any other context you
can carry it in your hand or keep it
down or sling it on your shoulder
all right sense if you carry the bag on
your little finger
it'll hurt so much yeah
if you carry like this less
if you sing it here much less if you
keep it down wonderful
the nature of life is such if you keep
your kermit back down it's not going to
go away it's going to travel with you
but it's your choice whether you want to
carry it on your head or it just comes
with you like baggage
let's say whatever baggage you carry
when you're traveling if you had to keep
it on your head through the entire
travel
terrible isn't it it's in the luggage
hold so it's good
this is all i'm saying karma means just
this you can keep it there it'll anyway
come
your name is marked on it
it will come don't worry it will not go
anywhere you can't lose it if you lose
your mind you will not lose your karma
if you lose your body you will not lose
your karma it will come with you you
don't have to worry where it will go
so because of your worry where it will
go you're carrying it on your head and
it hurts all the time because of the
sheer weight of it
not because it's good or bad certainly
it's heavy
thank you
thank you thank you very much
helping me set my bag down
that's good bye bag
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button